aber damals luca meine lieben freunde
ihr seht schon ich sitze hier mit einer
person die ihr nicht sehen mein name ist
ich habe heute auf jeden fall einige
fragen für meine mutter vorbereitet die
eventuell dem ein oder anderen bei
seinen eigenen eltern ein bisschen zu
unangenehm wären das zu fragen was mich
mal klar und da du ja so für alle eltern
sprichst ganz so den leuten vielleicht
ein oder anderen tipp geben meine kleine
schwester lässt mich nie in ruhe auf was
kann ich dagegen machen einfach mal mit
ihr sprechen
oder einfach zurück ärgern es kommt auch
aus alter an man muss ja auch ein
bisschen verständnis haben egal wie alt
ich würde zurück ärgert die sage ich
meiner mutter dass ich meine
jungfräulichkeit verloren habe
mir ist es auch wichtig das
kommt darauf an in welchem alter also es
spielt immer das alter eine rolle und
wenn man ein gutes verhältnis zu der
mutter hat und die auch verständnis hat
dann
muss man sich daran tasten verhüten es
wichtig welches ist das richtige alter
einen freund bzw eine freundin zu haben
jedes alter so
immer wichtig ob männlein weiblein
beziehung sind immer wichtig freunde zu
haben ich bin nach dem sportunterricht
nicht mit den anderen jungs duschen weil
ich mich unwohl fühle ich weiß ja nicht
warum diese person sich unwohl fühlt
also auch und wir sind alle nackt auf
die erde gekommen jeder entwickelt sich
irgendwie wenn man probleme hat kann man
auch mit jedem darüber sprechen es gibt
immer irgendwelche personen oder
stellen wo man hilfe bekommen kann ich
glaube ich stehe auf frauen wie sage ich
das meinen eltern meistens ist es ja so
dass die eltern ein gutes verhältnis hat
man ja aufgewachsen ist oder erzogen
worden ist beziehungsweise wenn man ja
ein behütetes heim hat oft haben die
eltern da auch schon ein gespür für die
gesehen dass die machen sich natürlich
nicht bemerkbar oder zeigen das nicht
aber ich glaube schon dass das die das
auch dann akzeptieren also das hoffe ich
immer das würde ich sage das jetzt
einfach mal so ich würde auf jeden fall
akzeptieren egal ob sich jemand in ihrer
oder seiner haut nicht wohl fühlt vom
geschlechtlichen her das gibt es ja auch
sehr oft das mädchen denken ach ich bin
eigentlich ein junge oder irgendwann
jungen feststellen eigentlich bin ich
doch 'ne frau richtig fühle mich gar
nicht wie ein junge oder ich fühle mich
nicht männlich habe also dagegen selbst
gar nicht mal so krasser und dann geht
es ja auch eher um die sexuelle
orientierung aber auch da glaube ich
einfach einen guten moment abwarten ich
kann auch freunde von mir die da weiß
ich dass die seit eine ahnung hier fünf
jahren homosexuell sind aber die eltern
business noch nicht so also ich kann ich
kann jede frage da verstehen dass das
für die person an sich schwierig wäre wo
ich aber selbst beste ist und kein
problem wäre aber kann man halt nicht so
in die haut rein gucken ich bin kurz
davor eine klasse wiederholen zu müssen
aber meine eltern wissen es noch nicht
was soll ich tun auch hier denke ich das
ist dass die eltern einen überblick
haben dass sie das auch
das heißt kurz davor wahrscheinlich
obert wenn ich die arbeit jetzt nicht
gut schreiben dann muss ich wiederholen
aber manchmal ist es auch wirklich der
bessere weg
einfach noch mal zu wiederholen ich habe
angst vor dem ersten mal wie wird das
ich glaube ehrlichkeit ist da auch das
wichtige einfach auf sich zukommen
lassen ehrlichkeit bringt immer das
meistens im leben das muss man schon
also stimmt einfach was euch selbst auch
nicht
stimmt
ich hatte aber nicht mein erstes mal die
frage von mir alle typen haben schon
bartwuchs warum dauert es bei mir so
lange ist das normal die frage hab ich
vor mir wie kann man die extra für euch
müsse das thema
jetzt nicht auf dem feld der fas die
brille ich finde das ganz egal ob also
früher eine zeit lang war es ja mode
alle schweizer zu sehen oder sich zeigen
zu lassen und es ist ja immer eine
hygienische sache auch ich glaube hier
wird zum beispiel auch nicht stehen aber
ich habe auch ich mal gesagt leute die
später bat uns haben kriegen auch später
erst verhalten oder eigentlich ob das
stimmt oder nicht keine ahnung was es
gibt irgendwie solche warte rollen die
kann sie betreuen habe ich mir mal
bestellt kam hier an bringt aber wenig
meine letzten freunde haben mich immer
verarscht woran weiß ich werde richtige
ist ich bin der ansicht man muss ein
fehler machen man muss wie heißt das man
muss mal den feuer anfassen weil man
sonst nicht mehr mitmachen kann genau
ich glaube ist es in der heutigen zeit
ganz ganz schwierig weil man so viel war
ein herausfinden kann über die ganzen
netz und
wenn man schlau ist dann hört man aber
da kommt man gar nicht drum rum der eine
rede zu der eine sagt 8 mit themen und
die hat doch schon das und der schon und
kennst du den ich ja man kriegt es in
der heutigen zeit sehr viel gesagt von
allen seiten und gerade auch was gesagt
dass mit social media mit installateur
das gleich bei der obwohl er mit dir
eigentlich ist unklar was bedeutet er
mittlerweile so viel aber ich würde mich
immer auf alles wo man sich denkt ja
wenn das herz sagt es gerade richtig
darauf einlassen aber mit vorsicht und
man lernt ja auch aus jeder sache
gebranntes kind weder das gebranntes
kind
dieser spruch raus nein kann ich meiner
mutter sagen dass ich rauche deine
tochter fingern zu rauchen wie sagt man
es ist ja auch wieder die sache haben
die eltern früher auch gebrauchen die
heute noch oder vielleicht haben sie
dann mehr verständnis oder wenn sich das
alles im rahmen hält mal eine zigarette
am tag denke ich dann kann man das auch
mal ausprobieren eine zigarette am tag
ist für dich im rahmen
ich will meinen freund zum ersten mal
mit nach hause bringen wie stelle ich
das am besten an auch wieder energie ist
das verhältnis zu den eltern scheinbar
ist der person das ja wichtig dass die
eltern kennenlernen oder sie kennen
lernen und das finde ich immer ganz
schön das ist ja auch
einfach
eine wertschätzung
den freund bzw freundin und ich würde
einfach den eltern sagen nun das ist mir
sehr wichtig dass ihr diese person
kennen lernt und
dann kann ich euch den mal vorstellen
und dann
einfach mitbringen ich werde in der
schule gemobbt was soll ich machen also
wenn das jetzt eben die grundschule ist
würde ich schon die lehrer auch
ansprechen
mobbing und mobbing ist ja nicht das
gleiche ob es jetzt eine ganze gruppe
ist die gegen einen sind oder ob es eine
person ist da steckt ja auch ganz viele
verschiedene arten for life ist auch
neid es ist oft der schwächere dass man
vor anderen dann auch und das dann leute
denken die fühlen sich besser dadurch
dass die andere runtermachen ja vor den
anderen vor den wahlen angeben oder
sagen wir nach sind also ich bin ganz
froh darüber dass ich so etwas in meiner
schule nie erleben muss ich auch noch
nie mitbekommen meiner schule gab es 100
prozentig auch aber das hat es nie so
richtig hautnah mitbekommen es gibt ja
ganz viele nummern in die nummer gegen
kummer oder kontaktmöglichkeiten aber
social media wo man den leuten schreiben
kann und tipps fragen kann ich hab das
wichtigste ist einfach sich an seine
freunde halten familie und einfach
darüber reden und das hört sich jetzt so
dumme an dieser tipp aber sport machen
weil man kann beim sport so viele
aggressionen rauslassen man arbeitet an
sich selber in seinem körper man stößt
ramona aus glück vormonat ja und dann
danach also wirklich sportlich
auch wenn es einfach gar nicht ja
einfach gar nicht reagieren oder einfach
so ja aber trotzdem nicht nur das thema
mobbing hat sich baden sondern wirklich
sport ist echt wichtig bei so was es
bringt einen wirklich weiter meine
eltern bevorzugen immer meine schwester
das ist so unfair warum ist das so aber
auch vielleicht ist das ja auch so ich
weiß nicht ob es jetzt wieder männlein
oder weiblein ist vielleicht ist die
schwester ja irgendwo schwächere wo die
eltern denken ich muss das kind mehr
unterstützen ihr denkt ich bin der chef
es
ist doch gar nicht so bei und die
plattform ihr nein noch mal wie war die
frage wann der eltern bevorzugen immer
meine schwester die hat ihren
schreibtisch ich nicht wo stehen die
fitnessgeräte in meinem zimmer jetzt
einer frau die hand recht da war ja auch
direkt vor mir was soll das sein wenn
wir noch ganz viele fragen in die
richtung ist 19 zu jung zum heiraten ich
will auswahl noch nicht mehr in
deutschland leben ich bin unbedingt
einen hund die kinder überzeugen ich
kann es gar nicht abwarten endlich
auszuziehen geschafft jetzt eine gute
beziehung zu haben aber die letzte frage
auf die wir uns heute wirklich
konzentrieren werden ist mein freund
will news von mir und ich vertraue ihm
eigentlich ist das dumm
nackt bilder
ausgedruckt oder digital
schon noch so ein poster okay
digital wahrscheinlich fordert der
freund oder will dann irgendwie bei
bilder von dir ja keine ahnung was ich
kann nur sagen ich nie machen niemals
und hier auch wenn er in dem moment noch
so lieb ist und dass dann alles gut wie
du keine ahnung was in euch irgendwann
trennen hat er diese bilder also das ist
wieder die sache das frauen und das war
halt in der heutigen zeit ja wirklich
anders als vor 14 ja ja das war ein ganz
schönes schlusswort bei der liebe
freunde ich das wieder gefallen das kann
einen daumen hoch unter dem video david
main kanal und klickt auf die leute wenn
ihr bei videos nicht verpassen wollte
der lust auf den zweiten teil
beantwortet fragen dann schreibt uns in
die kommentare und das letzte wort